one of the shortcomings of Donald Trump  was it was too much about him and not  enough about the team that he had  assembled in achieving the success that  he did Donald Trump did more for this  country in the four years that he was in  office politically meaning in making our  lives that much more prosperous than  almost any other sitting president the  problem is that there's such distaste  and we've talked about it that they  hatred for the individual had Donald  Trump put his party first meaning had  given more credit to the Republican  party yeah I think people would be more  willing to stick to voting Republican  meaning being against the Democratic  party or against the agenda as it is  today with Biden